IT'S TIME TO PLAY "BAD SANTA."
"BAD SANTA."
THE REAL SANTA CLAUS IS THE
MAGICAL PATRIARCH OF CHRISTMAS
WHO LIVES IN THE NORTH POLE AND
MAKES DREAMS COME TRUE.
BUT MOST PEOPLE WILL GO THEIR
WHOLE LIVES WITHOUT EVER SEEING.
HIM.
THE SANTAS YOU'RE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO ENCOUNTER ARE
OVERWEIGHT VAGRANTS WHOSE
PISS-STAINED LAP YOU ONLY LET
YOUR KIDS SIT ON ONE MONTH A
YEAR.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M ABOUT TO SHOW
YOU SOME FOOTAGE WE FOUND OF BAD
SANTAS, AND FOR 250 POINTS I
WANT YOU GUYS TO ANSWERS SOME
QUESTIONS THAT THESE VIDEOS
RAISE.
VERY IMPORTANT SOCIOLOGICAL
EXPERIENCE.
FIRST UP, THIS CLUMSY CLAUS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: SO THE QUESTION IS
WHAT DOES HE WANT FOR CHRISTMAS,
RANDY.
>> RECTAL RECONSTRUCTION
SURGERY.
>> TO BE FAIR THAT'S WHAT HE
WANTED BEFORE THE ACCIDENT.
>> Chris: THIS MAKES IT MORE OF
A PRIORITY.
CHRIS.
>> PLACE TO HIDE HIS WHISKEY
THAT ISN'T AN ICY RAIN GUTTER.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT UP.
THIS SANTA DOESN'T KNOW WHEN TO
SHUT HIS [BEEP] MOUTH.
>> WHEN I WAS SIX YEARS OLD, IF
YOU'RE THE REAL SANTA WHAT DID I
ASK FOR?
A BARBIE DOLL AND TIDDLYWINKS
>> I GOT A CHRISTMAS PRESENT FOR
YOU MYSELF.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: NOT REALLY SURE WHO
THAT APPEALS TOO.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: THE REAL SANTA LIVES
IN THE NORTH POLE, WHERE DOES
THIS SANTA LIVE?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS,
FLORIDA.
RIGHT.
>> I GUESS --
Chris: RANDY.
>> AT THE RITZ CARLTON IN THE
NUTCRACKER SUITE.
COME ON.
>> Chris: WELL DONE.
THINK ABOUT IT, RANDY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
>> DEFINITELY DESERVES A LITTLE
EXTRA --
>> I DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE ALLOWED
TO TAKE VICTORY LAPS.
I DID NOT.
>> I WAS TOLD TO STAND HERE.
Chris: I MEAN AFTER A COMEDY
TOUCHDOWN LIKE THAT IT'S OKAY.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> AFTER THIS I'M GOING TO DO
THE WORM.
>> Chris: OH MY GOSH.
YOU KNOW HOW TO DO THE WORM?
>> OH, BOTH DIRECTIONS.
Chris: CHRIS FAIRBANKS I WILL
GIVE YOU TWO HUNDRED POINTS IF
DO YOU THE WORM.
>> GET DOWN.
DO IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OH MY GOD.
YES!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YES.
YES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> GO, GO, GO.
>> RANDY IF IT'S ANY
CONSOLATION I THINK I BLEW OUT
BOTH KNEES.
>> CHRIS: NEXT UP, IT'S OL'
SAINT DICK.
(YELLING AND LAUGHING)
>> Chris: I REALLY HOPE THAT'S
NOT THAT GUY'S FAMILY.
WHAT DID YOU SEE SANTA DO TO
MOMMY UNDER THE MISTLETOE LAST
NIGHT.
RANDY.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THIS.
SANTA DOESN'T GO DOWN THE
CHIMNEY HE COMES IN THE BACK
DOOR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> YEP.
Chris: APRIL.
>> IT'S THE SANTA CLAUS TWO.
THAT'S WHEN YOUR MOM GETS DOUBLE
TEAMED BY SANTA AND TIM ALLEN.
>> UUUUGH!
>> A POPULAR MOVIE.